I hope you can hear me over the sound of
the waves crashing here is close the
sunset in hanya just a beautiful Greek
Cretan Venetian town and I want to talk
today about sort of the difference
between casual exchanges in the language
almost like hit-and-run exchanges if you
want and getting deep into a language
I've talked about it before I tried to
learn a few phrases so that I could
speak of it in Vietnam I wasn't
successful here of course I put a lot of
effort into Greek I've been at it for
about six months an hour or more a day
so I know quite a bit I'm listening to
podcasts on you know the building of the
Acropolis and with the help of
transcripts and studying it on link I'm
able to follow and I can listen to these
you know I bought a grammar book I
always like to buy grammar books and
there so I bought some excellent books
here on Greek where they're not too
loose not too much in the way of
exercises but a lot of examples
especially helping helping you get used
to the cases you know whether it be the
genitive in other words of something to
something etc so I've been reading
through these I find that I know most of
the verbs because my the mini-story
series in length focuses on the most
common verbs so I have most of the verbs
of course their issues with tenses
but I feel quite comfortable but as I've
said before I'm traveling with some
friends from Vancouver
we mostly speak Chinese so I don't have
a chance to really get into in-depth
conversations with people but I can make
polite conversation and of course when
you just make polite conversation you
repeat the same words over and over
again you're not extending yourself I'm
not reaching into my passive vocabulary
to bring out more words that I could use
if I had a few hours of conversation I
could do that however what my exposure
to grief has done it has made me so
interested in in Greece even here in
Crete I mean the history of this country
starting from the Minoan civilization
4,500 years ago through the classical
Greek period the Roman period Byzantium
Venetian period Turks and then you know
modern independent Greece to get into
all of that now via the language I could
I'm not far away from the Emperor read
you know history books in green and of
course then you can you pick up all that
vocabulary that you need to have for
in-depth conversations with people and
and my goal and I guess I guess that's
part of the you know what's behind link
is my interest is to get to that level
and then that's what I did with
Ukrainian and I have to go back to
polish and do it more and so I think
there's a and the surprising thing in a
way is that in order to even have that
casual conversation I find you need you
need a fair amount of depth in the
language where I so giving back to my
example of Vietnamese just alert try to
remember a few phrases for the week that
I'm gonna be in Vietnam it didn't work
for me the same was true in my first
visit to Portugal when I even spent a
month or so trying to you know see how
Spanish converts to Portuguese and I
wasn't able to
use it because you know it's even casual
conversation in a language implies a
two-way communication so it implies that
you can understand what is said to you
and and that does take a bit of time but
it's all a matter of our goals like I
was sitting on a bench reading my Greek
grammar book and in behind me was a
person who was touting his restaurant
you know the Greek I don't know manager
order of his restaurant and he was able
to you know invite people in German and
French and English and maybe if a
Russian person had walked by he would
have been able to do it in Russian and
so he has certain phrases that he can
use and that works for him he's not
interested in French history or German
history I don't think and so that's fine
I think everyone has to have their goal
but at my I must say I'm excited I'm so
excited about having embarked and
learning Greek much like I felt about
the other languages that I've I've
learned and now it's sort of the
beginning of a period of engagement with
Greece I can always come back to Greece
and each time I will speak better and
I'll learn more about Greece so and that
is what turns my crown crank what makes
me excited what makes me excited about
my visit here I'm just at the beginning
of my Greek journey six months into the
language and that's all I have to say
today and I'm using my selfie stick so
we'll see how this turns out and I hope
that you can hear me over the waves bye
for now
and on
zatia and
sandhya man definition so on and you can
just walk along
over there around the corner and it just
keeps on going
a cuter
our polish Lines's narrow streets for
the shops and stop trendy people
[Music]